what would the the best outcome of that
have been Jim Jordan or Byron Donald's
look I I think that Jim Jordan is our
most talented member
I think he's our hardest working member
he is one of my mentors he inspires me
but you know it got to a point where
there were six holdouts where you don't
we didn't want to drive McCarthy into
the arms of the Democrats right so once
the margin gets that low McCarthy could
in theory have gone to the Democrats
gotten you know four five six of them to
get instant covid in exchange for
draining our subpoena Authority and then
he would have ascended to the
speakership anyway all of the features
of our deal would have dissolved and
then every time we didn't send a
subpoena to hold government accountable
he could have said well that's Matt
Gates's fault so we didn't want to put
him in that position the country in that
position the house in that position and
so that's why we crafted what we thought
was the a deal that was not reliant on
trust but that had clear enforcement
triggers